the girag an experience yeah but you
ever have a friend go crazy on you
yeah I've had friends that like
legitimately lost their mind I can't
talk to them anymore like like you had
talked to him about events and his
version of events were just like so not
what actually happened oh this is a
person that's lost their marbles yeah
yeah it happens you can temporarily lose
your marbles a permanent mention or
permanently yeah but I think that like I
mean yes permanently of course there's
like no I'm not saying through
psychedelics either well I know you're I
know you I'm just saying people that
just can't keep it together anymore and
for whatever reason whether it's a
combination of life stress and
biological situation whatever the [ __ ]
they've got going on you know uniquely
in their own brain but some people just
all of a sudden not there anymore not
keeping it together do they think
they're keeping it together sometimes
yeah I mean it's broad you know broad
range right there's all kinds of yeah it
sucks man people the brain is an organ
and it malfunctions and and sometimes
you go nuts and that's and you get
stigmatized for it which really sucks
because if you like because that just
adds to the problem like if you you know
I you see somebody in a cast and you're
like oh what happened your arm and
they'll tell you oh you know whatever I
fell down but you you talk to someone
who's been like hospitalized for a few
weeks and they tell ya I to go to the
hospital in ER vez break down I went
crazy [ __ ] my pants threw my dog through
a window yeah you're like you know you
you'll want you want to be compassionate
but there's some part of you that's like
oh now this is a crazy person it's like
it's just the something happened the
operating system temporarily crashed and
quite often I think that could be a very
good thing I think that having your your
personality or your ego or crash can
often mean that you were trying to be
somebody that you aren't and some people
invest so much energy so much energy in
defining yeah they just want to be
something you know there were a kid
their mother was telling them you should
be like this and then they try to be
like this and they hold up this thing
they're always working to hold up this
giant tail feather and it kicked their
arms start shaking and that they can't
hold it up and that's that's
when they have like anger outbursts or
suddenly like their friends are like you
you turned into someone that I've never
met I don't even know who that is it's
like no that is you met them you met
underneath the tailfeather the seething
sea of anger and disappointment and
sadness they move it you met that thing
that they're they're trying to avoid by
looking up at this mask they're holding
up to the world but that [ __ ]
seething sea of disappointment anger and
horror and sadness that's where it's at
man you got to go into that thing and
for some people the only way they can go
into that is by having a full-scale
nervous breakdown because then they can
have permission to dive into that into
that awful vortex of darkness because
underneath that vortex of darkness is
paradise underneath that that's love and
happiness and joy and connection and
tranquility and all that stuff and
everyone thinks that the way to get to
that point is by avoiding this awful
black forest that surrounds the Garden
of Eden which is inside everybody it's
inside everybody it's there it's there
and it doesn't matter you know you can
work out and that will definitely give
you a temporarily temporary good feeling
but until you address the internal
structures that you haven't acknowledged
you're always going to go back to that
place where you find yourself morose and
depressed and angry and you don't know
why you always go back to that place
until you sit with the sadness inside of
you you have to do that what you're
describing is coming out of the closet
and it you know yeah for a lot of people
that is what it is man it's coming out
of the closet and there's a lot of
closet clothes there's not just the gay
closet there's all kinds of closet
there's the artist closet some people
are [ __ ] accountants they're wearing
suits and their ties on tight and
they're [ __ ] like organized and
discipline but inside they're probably
painters they probably want it [ __ ]
paint they want to paint dayglo
mountains down at the beach that's what
they really are but their daddy or their
mommy wanted them to be a good little
business man so they became this thing
that's the opposite of what they are
this is the verse in the bhagavad-gita
God forgive me because I've quoted it
way too many times but it's it's better
to be an honest street sweeper than a
dishonest King it's better to be a
happy guy brushing [ __ ] Leafs up the
street than it is to be some zillionaire
who inside is dying or none or miserable
mostly num-nums the work most people are
just not as long as these people can
quantify on paper
I still have a X million dollar home my
car still cost X thousand dollars this
suit is an ex suit I am still ahead I am
NOT going to abandon all these things as
long as they don't see through the
[ __ ] the game they think they're
winning that's right yeah yeah it's
almost like you have to fall to to
really that's what you got to appreciate
those moments when it all falls apart on
you because that means you've got an
opportunity to try it again let's take a
new fresh perspective this is the cool
thing that at this retreat I went to
this guy jack Kornfield sigh which I
really loved what a great name by the
way
yeah with a k' not a seed jack Kornfield
mortal kombat k jack Kornfield but he uh
he's really cool man but he was like a
cool with a kid yeah he's with yet yet
like the cigarette and corny no this guy
was awesome and he was one of the things
he talked about is in some religious
tradition how they like hold the
scriptures rabbi like had his students
hold the scriptures over their heart and
when they were memorizing them and they
would say why do we do this and he said
so that when your heart breaks they'll
fall in and it's a beautiful idea which
is that heart break is actually your ego
cracking and the moment that cracks
you're in the experience of truth and
when you're in the experience of truth
that's when you can really become who
you are but but to get to who you are
it's like when you know a bone heals the
wrong way like that's what a lot of
people's entire personality is it's like
a bone that grew the wrong way and that
needs a [ __ ] take a snap a crack you
know it's wheat you get that through
Slava yeah you need that that initial
[ __ ] thing and it's a beautiful
analogy and it hurts it hurts but we're
paying avoiding creatures so we think
that so we're always running away from
this pain but the problem is as we're
running away from pain we're still
exactly in pain it's basically like
being on fire and running away from
water you're just running away from the
water because you for some I don't know
that's a stupid analogy
now I'm doing great up into that yeah
you had a lot of great points what it's
true you know there's the monster in the
dark and the faster you run the more
likely you are to run into something
that's actually going to hurt you as
opposed to turning around and saying oh
[ __ ] there is no monster no monster you
know but you're never going to know that
until you stop and turn around ya know
and in some cases people don't have the
discipline or the the assistance or the
the balls to stop and turn around so
they have to trip over something and
then there's like oh yep that is that
story this classic story of someone
hiding a secret and going completely out
of control because of the pressure of
hiding that like that's the Ted Haggerty
who's the secretly gay guy who's
preaching against gay people Ted Haggard
okay yeah in Colorado yeah that could
was snorting meth off his gay lovers
yeah yeah yeah we was Jenna going so far
the other way
he's just so off the rails being himself
he's beat himself he was a guy who likes
to snort meth off of [ __ ] let's do a
little math and it likes it well does
suck a few [ __ ] but I would say he
wasn't being himself what I would say is
that his his behavior was so extreme
because he was seeking balance between
that and the other [ __ ] in his life
whereas if he weren't living that he'd
be right in the middle right yeah well
to get to get to the middle you know the
way to get to the middle weirdly is
whatever the behavior is that you're
doing that you're so horrified about and
terrified of sometimes that the really
weird idea is this is like something
that I like that Rhonda says which is
like don't if you don't feel like
meditating don't meditate don't force it
don't impose this on yourself keep doing
the thing you're doing that's upsetting
you so much have the balls to keep doing
the [ __ ] thing that you're doing keep
doing it society is going to tell you
don't be like this stop being like this
you have to change that's what your
parents always say the idea is like no
sink into what you are right now just be
that thing stop resisting exactly where
you are right now is perfect and that's
a hard truth to grasp because you think
right away you think yeah what about
[ __ ] Jeffrey Dahmer
is he perfect well what about the
leopard when you're seeing a leopard rip
apart of a creature is that thing purr
is that a perfect mom
I don't think the leopard [ __ ] them and
then kills them but you know what Ducks
do Ducks are necrophiliacs are they
[ __ ] evil creatures yes I think they
are well yeah they are made that Phil
Robertson guy a very famous person he
invented a call for the lamp lamp and
now poor gay people have to hear that a
man's anus is not as good as a woman's
vagina can you imagine if you made the
choice for a man's anus and you hear
this [ __ ] big bearded fashionista
with his camel on a bandanna absolute
fact that's so weird I never thought of
that big bearded Christian Bible slang
and fashionista and he tells you that
your choice was incorrect and in fact
the woman's vagina is the better choice
the man's anus I mean come on guys but
how can you say that if you haven't
experienced it maybe yeah I think he has
again the balance theory I think he's so
outspoken on that issue like most of
these Homo phobes are because their home
jerking off to gay porn that you know
otherwise you just don't give a [ __ ] it
just doesn't actually matter right you
know it doesn't come up in a GQ
interview Duffing right it's like duh
ready yeah really care people are gay
duh you really care the two guys love
each other and that you are you against
love yeah you only like love if it's a
man and a woman like a [ __ ] man really
yeah it's a dog it's duh and you're
talking about men's anuses in GQ maybe
you've got some issues to think about
shouldn't we just be talking about ducks
ducks anus isn't that your host you know
ducks ganas like you shoot ducks all the
time right that's your thing let's just
talk about murdering ducks yeah why you
gotta talk about men what I'm talking
about
[ __ ] quality adding this into blood
sacks well the only way you can live
that fake life as if it's fake the
actual you know this this like this
puritanical ideal they've held up it's
not natural and they haven't been really
living it anyway they've been pretending
to be living it be freaks in this sort
of a rebound sort of a way to balance
everything out and I think that
ultimately that's being exposed over and
over and over and over again to the
point where it's not going to be a
viable option anymore like powdered wigs
aren't a viable option yes can't wear a
[ __ ] powdered wig you know and you
can't pretend you're this you know Rick
Santorum guy you know just as a
it man who believes in the Bible and
doesn't want to see gays get married
doesn't want to ruin the institution of
marriage with homosexual activity that's
been shunned upon in the Bible may I
quote and you're like oh [ __ ] criminy
what's going on really what's going on
behind the scenes with you cat what was
in your head yeah I keep waiting for it
to get to that point where anybody who's
got a big problem with homosexuality is
by default admitting to their own
homosexual life but I've been waiting 30
years for America to go come on this is
too silly to be real Ronald Reagan are
you kidding that guy was such a joke but
you know he's Saint Ronald and the seeds
mounted 30 years ago
why even then well even then there was a
lot of others who voted for him but do
you remember the criticism though it was
pretty open there was a lot of people
that didn't like him I remember what he
was in but not enough that he didn't win
49 out of 50 states in his re-election
listen man I'm not saying that you know
he didn't dominate the vast majority of
the you know I mean there was a lot of
idiots back then but the difference
between the way people look at him now
and the way people looked at him then
now it's almost all glowing when people
talk about ring and I hardly ever hear
any criticism yeah you don't hear about
iran-contra Nicaragua no serve it out
Oliver freeze yeah Oliver North all over
and all that craziness and you know yeah
but my point my point is that this idea
that suddenly we're gonna wake up and
realize how ridiculous it is and it's a
Rick Santorum is too ridiculous to be
real it's [ __ ] what's her name Sarah
Palin mmm you know I I am amazed that
how flexible the reality muscle seems to
be that people are willing to accept
this stuff that Frank Zappa was laughing
about 40 years ago boy I wonder if
they're accepting it though I wonder I
think that you watch these shows enough
and it creates the illusion of
acceptance but then if you if anywhere
on the internet or and you just see this
constant rebellion against that kind of
square mainstream homophobic angry
personality and but you watch Fox News
and yeah you watch Fox News or you
watched anything on TV and it's an
illusion you know you watch the the
commercials everything's this big
illusion you watch the commercials and
it's like
people go in and buy a car and make it
seems normal it seems totally normal
that people are going in to get deeply
in debt to the banks that all seems
incredibly normal but then more and more
on the internet you see like people
rebelling against this and showing how
the bankers like the whole system is
this [ __ ] up thing and emerging things
like Bitcoin which are like slowly
moving the energy away from it I don't
know I didn't know you mean I don't
think it's going to be a sudden thing I
think it's going to be more like a just
a gradual shift as people just stop
watching TV that's that's going to
happen people are just gonna you know I
Drive down the street billboards for
[ __ ] like amazon.com shows you know
like billboards for shows that aren't
really controlled by these big Netflix
Netflix you yeah yeah is an Amazon just
another big networking I mean you know
it doesn't matter if it's a network or
it's a international conglomerate or
whatever is it's big money it is but
you're right but that's just the
billions the reality is it's you're not
that but them yeah but that's not it's
not right because the media is a very
different thing the media when you're
talking about television you're talking
about a very hard thing to get into the
medium you're talking about in turn
you're talking about an incredibly easy
right get into literally open to almost
anyone with an internet connection you
can make a YouTube video doesn't cost
you a goddamn dime yeah you have a
laptop that has a camera on it you talk
any what you make a youtube video that
yeah that's a big change that's not just
a big change that might be the biggest
change in human history it might be the
biggest change since a monkey ate a
mushroom all right certainly since the
printing press the practic printing
press was a major for sure giant you
know and in similar in the sense that it
it took the power of communication away
from very few and gave it to a lot more
right sort and that's sort of one of the
more fascinating things about this is
that they're you know even if Amazon
does put something online it's no better
than I just Dean who has like you know
45 [ __ ] billion write followers and
cheap every video she put there's people
like that that just became famous for
the internet no jennamarbles is another
one right yeah she's got like millions
and millions and millions of hits okay
yeah here's what it is here's what it is
cuz I I've just been reading Sheldrake's
new book
science set free and he talks about
morphic resonance or something and I
know you have some I think you skeptical
about Sheldrake but it's like when you
just have TV TV is a tuning fork and
when there was no internet it was just
TV and it was a depiction of here's what
a family looks like here's what people
tend it's corporations saying here's
what people do when they're healthy and
that creates a tuning fork effect which
is like if you're watching it enough
you're going to either resonate with it
or in and feel like yes I'm doing great
I have a wife and a house in a car and a
job and that's great I'm in tune with
what everyone else is doing but that's
an illusion that's never been what
everyone else is doing it's just what
massive conglomerates are sending out
there either in the form of hypnotic
content that keeps you glued to your
seat as you watch corporations try to
get you in debt to buy cars you know
it's it's it's generally it's just it's
it's a the whole thing is just a a
tuning all of society in a way that
society maybe isn't meant to be tuned at
all and so with the internet now you
have all these different smaller tuning
forks you know your podcast is a tuning
fork people tune into the stuff that you
talk about and the different people that
you bring on the podcast send out
information that causes a new kind of
tuning to start happening so that's why
when you watch like Huckabee you'd
really feel like you're like listening
to somebody sing off-key because you're
not resonating you're not resonating
you've been tuned in to a whole
different thing which is what the
Internet's I think one of the major
things the internet is done you know you
get these communities read it you can
get tuned into the reddit frequency
quite easily where suddenly it all just
starts making sense and that is why that
you know the duck dynasty guy or any of
these weirdos who are who are just
ultimately just angry people that's why
they seem so [ __ ] crazy or they play
angry people on TV right because I think
a lot of these people aren't even you
know like that the Republic dynasty guy
the duck dynasty guy has been giving
speeches like that for years these
biblical retreats and stuff he's been
doing that for this video so that's his
real stick he's not he's at fire and
brimstone god-fearing Christian man it
was living on the wrong side of the law
and Jesus at one point
time and then turned it all around and
wants to let everybody know about the
evils of sin he's an old dummy
that's what he is he's an old dummy that
loves a scientific name for EM hey he's
an old dummy - probably just one time
suck the dick and liked it way too much
if someone sucked his dick and it's his
favorite moment ah look back as
childhood and he's turned it into you
know career I bet he was hunting ducks
when it happened I bet he was not even
that duck blonde they're all liquored up
moonshine he wasn't hunting ducks at
that right when he came into like some
guy's mouth years ago out in the out in
the mud he saw it's why they call it a
duck boy yeah sorry ducky find pleasure
and shame mixed inside of me like I'm
just gonna kill dogs from now on and
never think about this duck she didn't
see [ __ ] your mother ng [ __ ] your father
didn't see [ __ ]
nobody son [ __ ] Jimmy bedroom khatoun
could you humanity that's really what it
was all was just a duck song get his
dick sucked by a guy he's like [ __ ] that
it didn't happen did nap I need to kill
ducks I think that's something like that
happen man it's something like that
happened yeah but you know man
like what you do with with you know sex
at dawn creates a residence where it's
like it's a it's a shame reliever it's a
shame reducer man because your book I
think it has been it's such a
compassionate book for people who are
stuck in monogamous relationships and
feel guilty about the fact that they are
attracted to other people and that's
like that guilt used to be a normal
guilt that was actually considered like
oh something must be going wrong with
your relationship if you're thinking
about [ __ ] other people and your book
makes shows like no actually that's just
nature happening through you you don't
have to feel guilty about it or like
something's off balance in you it's just
completely normal it doesn't mean you
have to go and [ __ ] other people but at
least now you don't have to feel like I
must not love her anymore
or she must not love me anymore what's
that have to do with [ __ ] ducks
country music song that's the glue yeah
the glue that connects cheese [ __ ]
ducks and in the sadness you have for
not wanting to be monogamous yeah
muezzin chants Ricky right that's the
glue yeah keeps it all together the glue
that holds the oh that's why you need to
listen to Phil Roberts
and that that goddamn communist Andy
that puts them on is that what it's on
to any cuz not hilarious it's on A&E
Annie used to be like [ __ ]
masterpiece theater [ __ ] yeah pleased to
have like you know arts and
entertainment live is you know
interesting fascinating programming and
stimulated the mind don't sell cars I
know it's our entry yeah now it's
[ __ ] you know people let found a
storage box what's in the storage box
yeah yeah but there's a lot of good
stuff in there I bet the nuttin in the
war after the break yeah yeah I wonder
what how much you take for that but 500
I can't give you five I need three yeah
I gotta get at least four I don't know
that's a commercial a narrative art I
take this my last offer and I'll be in a
serious cut to commercial
Wow wonder what his last offers gonna be
he got him down to three I wish I could